[Music]
on this Tuesday night intensifying space
race what an asset official fears could
happen if China beats the U.S to the
punch we need to protect the interest of
the International Community
pricey pipeline they were set up for
failure how construction costs for Trans
mountains Expansion Project
Canadian media versus meta the push to
probe the tech giant over its new ban on
news
plus less is more it's not like this
delicious circle of satisfaction the
benefits for both companies and staff
with four day work weeks
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight for an answer good
evening to you thanks for joining us it
is seen as a gateway mission to a future
flight to Mars today the Artemis 2 crew
including Canadian astronaut Jeremy
Hansen got a first look at the
spacecraft that will fly them around the
Moon late next year but during today's
press conference a comment raised by
NASA administrator Bill Nelson shed
light on the geopolitical reality of the
first crude moon mission in more than
half a century there is an intensifying
space race between the U.S and China
Mike trolley now on the rocky lunar
relations
the Artemis II crew look ready to
conquer the cosmos for the first time
they were able to see the ship that will
catapult them into a lunar orbit late
next year which Canadian astronaut
Jeremy Hansen said sent shivers down
their spines I already knew going to the
moon was hard but boy it's harder than I
thought Artemis is about the 386 000
kilometer three-day Voyage to the moon
but the big picture is so much larger
because what NASA really wants to do is
complete the 225 million kilometer
six-month trip to Mars but all their
best laid plans could be moot if they
don't get to the moon first we're in a
space race with China you see the
actions of the Chinese government on
Earth
they go out and claim some International
islands in the South China Sea and then
they claim them as theirs indeed China
began building an air base in the
spratly islands in 2015 staking its
claim to All fishing and gas resources
today's space race has more similarities
to that economic land grab than it does
to the space race of the 50s and 60s
which saw the U.S and Russia competing
for bragging rights both NASA and
China's space agency are eyeing similar
Landing spots near the moon's South Pole
which is a Pock marked with deep dark
craters that are believed to be filled
with ice and with it the resources to
create fuel for the trip to Mars so
naturally I don't want China to get to
the South Pole first with humans
and then say this is ours stay out thus
far it appears that NASA has a leg up on
China the Artemis 3 moon landing with
humans is scheduled for December 2025
while China's plans are to land robots
by 2026 and humans before 2030 or so
they say another Advantage for NASA 28
countries have signed on to the Artemis
Accords with the aim to share in
whatever is discovered and if indeed we
find water in abundance
there that could be utilized for future
Crews we want to make sure that that's
available to all but China isn't playing
by the Artemis rules and just like the
first space race it's all about who gets
there first microwave Global News
Toronto
the construction cost overruns for the
pipeline that Ottawa bought are
jaw-dropping and trans Mountain's plans
to pass those costs on to oil companies
who plan to ship their product on the
line appear to be fading fast purchased
from Kinder Morgan for 4.7 billion
dollars and initially expected to cost
5.4 billion to build the price of 20 the
line connecting Edmonton and Burnaby has
ballooned to 30.9 billion by March of
2023 and money is still being spent
Trans Mountain had planned to recover
some of those funds by hiking the price
if using the pipeline but as Heather
York's West reports oil companies and
Canada's energy Regulators have pushed
back
in the hearts of Canada's energy sector
the Trans Mountain pipeline expansion
was seen as a Beacon of Hope everybody
was excited
everybody wanted to be a part of it at
one time this pipeline engineer a man
will call Brian worked as a construction
manager on a section of the Trans
Mountain pipeline project we've agreed
to protect Brian's identity over fears
that sharing his experiences might
impact his current employment I know for
a lot of the people that were involved
in the construction there is a sense of
you know we we messed this one up but
they're more disappointed that you know
due to the poor planning and just a lack
of forethought that they were set up for
failure originally expected to cost
between five and six billion dollars
costs a balloon to more than 30 billion
so far are you surprised that this
project space is such a large cost
override no no uh you know you look at
the initial cost estimate of 78 billion
it was completely infeasible
moving out to start construction not all
of the little things like land
acquisition and right-of-way survey were
completed it uh it was sort of starting
a little bit unprepared so to speak
Trans Mountain says 70 percent of the
project followed the pipeline's original
right of way and that contractors were
engaged early to develop construction
execution plans adding there were many
reasons why the project experienced cost
growth and schedule delays
when the pipeline is finally in
operation it will start making some of
its investment back oil producers have
signed 20-year contracts to ship their
product down the line but the proposed
cost of shipment is already causing
conflict Suncor Synovus and Canadian
natural say the fees on the table are
too high they're worried about the
Tariff and they're going to probably
argue about the actual cost Canada's
energy regulator rejected trans
Mountain's request to fast-track its
proposed fee hikes a series of hearings
will be held to review the company's
application instead but based on the
contracts signed Trans Mountain will
never be able to recover its
construction overruns in Revenue alone
so very likely if the federal government
is going to want to sell this they're
going to have to take a write down and
sell it at a much reduced value compared
to what has been spent so far citing an
independent economic impact assessment
trans says the pipeline's construction
will contribute more than 9 billion
dollars to Canada's GDP over the next 20
years while ensuring Canada receives
fair market value for its oil something
that is currently sold at a discount
well the project itself was a great idea
it was great I I just really feel that
it was poorly executed resulting in one
of the costliest increases for a
pipeline project in recent memory with
Canadians likely on the hook for a big
part of that bill
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
and we have much more on the story on
our website from journalist kamiya
razavi to read more about the rise in
costs at the Trans Mountain pipeline
expansion head to globalnews.ca global
national
as leader of the opposition Pierre
pauliev is a well-known outspoken critic
of the liberal government and prime
minister Justin Trudeau today the
conservative party launched a new effort
to introduce Canadians to another side
of polyev
who is pure poliov
many know him the conservatives have
launched an advertising Blitz portraying
poliev as an approachable family man as
Mackenzie gray reports pauliev has a lot
of ground to make up with one key group
of Voters
Everything feels broken in Canada from
political Pitbull to personal profile
three new ads from the conservative
party are a big money bet on refining
Pierre poliev's image the conservatives
are trying to Define themselves or else
they risk being defined Paulie have
recently stopped wearing his glasses at
events and often ditches a suit and tie
for more casual attire the new look
echoed in the ads as a guy who loves me
for who I am the conservative Leader's
wife also featured prominently along
with their two children annapoli have
narrating one of the spots and tweeted
it out before her husband a senior
conservative Source saying Canadians are
likely to see a lot more of her his wife
is really a secret weapon I mean anybody
that saw her speak at the convention
um about a year year and a half ago
thought wow you know what an asset that
is and the conservatives hope their
secret weapon will boost her husband
standing with women pauliev is behind 21
points to Justin Trudeau with women one
of the few places the Liberals are head
of the conservatives overall 59 percent
of Canadians moderately or strongly
disapprove of the Prime Minister but not
that far behind as pauliev at 50 percent
a higher number than the past four
conservative leaders after nearly a year
in the top job well he would probably
was told that he needed to soften his
tone uh to try to reassure uh the the
center of the political spectrum and
also those Suburban writings that he
needs to win to win an election but
pauliev's tough tone has propelled the
conservatives to a 10-point lead over
the Liberals when you drill down on the
regional level it shows the
conservatives will likely need more
support to comfortably form government
we mentioned every election the GTA
there's over 30 seats in there and many
seats were won by very close margins for
the Liberals the conservatives have
dropped three million dollars on these
ads and they easily could have spent
more with a substantial lead in
fundraising numbers and no election
period rules pharah impacting the amount
they could spend
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie and Those ads will appear on
Facebook and Instagram feeds but news
articles will not and Canadian media
Outlets are urging Canada's competition
Bureau to do something about that
they're asking for an investigation into
Meta Meta is the parent company if those
social media platforms and it's banned
on news it's retaliation for the online
news act or bill c18 which is supposed
to level the playing field for Tech
Giants and newsrooms as tariya Israel
explains it could have the opposite
effect
if you're searching for news on Facebook
or Instagram you won't find it meta is
blocking news on their platforms in
retaliation for c18 which requires Tech
Giants to pay Publishers and
broadcasters for sharing their content
you cannot block access to news which
deprives Canadians of news news media
Canada the CBC and the Canadian
Association of broadcasters which
includes Global News are urging Canada's
competition Bureau to investigate what
they're calling meta's abuse of its
dominant position they control something
like 70 percent of the market see teen
is meant to bring advertising dollars
back into shrinking newsrooms in a
statement Heritage Minister Pascal
Santosh says Metta would rather block
their users from accessing good quality
and local news instead of paying their
fair share to news organizations but the
tech giant calls c18 unfair and
unworkable what the platforms want to do
here is they want to avoid regulation
media experts question how much the
complaint will actually accomplish the
competition Bureau is known for taking a
long time to come to a decision Facebook
book has done this before when Australia
introduced similar legislation the
impasse eventually ended and tech
companies now pay Australian news
organizations approximately 200 million
dollars a year the reason I worked in
Australia is the Australian government
got out of the way and went back to the
status quo which is letting the
platforms and the News industry work out
their own deals the competition Bureau
confirms it has received the complaint
but it won't comment on what kind of
recourse if any it will take the bureau
insists examining the conduct of large
digital companies remains a top priority
Global News Ottawa
working smarter not harder coming up why
these four-day work week is gaining
traction
the largest four-day workweek trial in
North America has wrapped and hours
worked or down but efficiency is up and
gaviola speaks with one of the Canadian
companies involved
get your Workforce to do the same amount
of work or more in a shorter amount of
time at first the equation didn't make
sense to the CEO of fresh squeezed ideas
a pharmaceutical strategy company I was
definitely tentative and apprehensive on
it the company's first stab at adopting
a four day work week didn't work out so
well but with some tweaks Freedom Friday
gave way to flexible Friday what
happened for our people is actually an
improvement in their overall emotional
and mental health they've had more time
in you know kind of in their personal
world to do the things that our passion
projects for themselves and that
actually allows them to bring more of
themselves into work
41 companies took part in the four-day
Work Week trial which spanned six months
including nine Canadian companies all of
which are keeping the four-day structure
after the pilot hundreds and if not
thousands of people connecting with us
and and want uh some details about how
we've done it four day week Global runs
the increasingly popular pilot programs
improving workflows cutting down on time
wasters like meetings that could have
been an email the result fewer sick
calls and increased productivity over
fewer days something like this delicious
circle of satisfaction that starts to
impact so I'm happy it works I'm happy
at home I do other things outside the
work and then I'm happy about the work
proponents call it win-win employees
don't see a reduction in earnings
workers are more engaged after all the
five-day work week is a holdover from
the Industrial Revolution and the
pandemic has opened people's eyes to
what is now possible at work and at home
and Global News Toronto
[Music]
War of Attrition I had these sobering
updates on Ukraine's counter-offensive
against Russia
[Music]
thank you
thousands of people in Ireland are
saying their last goodbye to Sinead
O'Connor the singer's family invited the
public to line the streets of Frey for
her funeral procession fans love flowers
and handwritten notes outside O'Connor's
former family home thanking her for her
music and her voice O'Connor was 56
years old
tens of thousands of Scouts including
some Canadians began arriving at their
new accommodations in South Korea today
they're being put up in University dorms
corporate training centers and hotels
the government abandoned the huge
Coastal campsite for the world Scout
Jamboree ahead of a tropical storm the
event has already struggled with health
concerns after hundreds of participants
became sick due to the Heat
and Ukraine officials are accusing
Russia of targeting emergency workers
drawn to the scene of an Air Attack
at least seven people were killed in the
strike on a residential building and
hotel 80 others were hurt Rescuers were
scrambling to dig out survivors when a
second Missile hit the attack happened
in the Eastern dunesque region partly
occupied by Russia
Kiev is focused on reclaiming lost
territory and holding back invading
forces but as Crystal commencing Reports
progress is slow and it's complicated
step by step Ukraine's military
commander-in-chief says the country is
creating conditions to advance store
mayorsk in the Donetsk region is one of
a handful of villages reclaimed since
the start of the summer offensive
it's hard they have pre-sighted zones
methodically destroyed roads as this 24
year old Marine Russia's defense
minister last month commented on their
well-constructed defensive lines and
firing positions former U.S ambassador
to Ukraine Bill Taylor says an earlier
start to the counter-offensive would
have benefited Ukraine but just wasn't
possible they were digging in deeply and
in depth and putting in the obstacles in
the minefields that we're now reading
about
so had the ukrainians been able uh to go
on the on the offensive sooner it would
have given the Russians less time to
prepare it the Ukrainian president told
the BBC last month that progress has
been slower than desired but added some
people believe this is a Hollywood movie
and expect results now it's not
the West has invested heavily with money
and weapons including a U.S donation of
cluster Munitions a weapon that while
banned by many countries could help
Ukraine break through those heavily
entrenched Russian lines the slowness of
the provided provision of some of that
Aid is a huge factor in why this
offensive is going as slowly as it is
fighter jets are Another Western promise
with training in Romania set to start
later this month it's unlikely they'll
be used in this counter-offensive
I think it's very inappropriate at best
for us for anybody in the west or
anybody outside of Ukraine to be
critical of uh of of Ukrainian military
decisions Ukraine meanwhile is hitting
Russian bridges in occupied areas and
tactical storage locations in support of
their counter-offensive Crystal
gemancing Global News London
[Music]
next the hype and skepticism surrounding
a potentially massive scientific
breakthrough
[Music]
the Science World is buzzing over an
apparent breakthrough in the field of
quantum mechanics a team of Korean
scientists says it has synthesized a
superconducting material they call LK 99
saying it could be a new era for mankind
if it's true it could make everything
from batteries to power lines and
computers far more efficient scientists
around the world have been trying to
replicate the findings but as Redmond
Shannon reports it's starting to look
like this breakthrough may be too good
to be true
when this simple video was released
along with two scientific papers last
month it was claimed to Herald a
Monumental breakthrough the Korean
researchers said it shows a room
temperature superconductor that they
called LK 99
across the globe it created huge
excitement that this Holy Grail had been
found a superconductor has two
remarkable properties first it can
levitate in a magnetic field and as the
name suggests it is amazingly efficient
at conducting electricity electrical
appliances like a computer or a cell
phone heat up when they're working hard
that's because there is electrical
resistance within the wiring effectively
it's energy wasted a superconductor
material would solve that issue and
potentially so many others power
generation and storage could become far
more efficient MRI machines much cheaper
and cell phone batteries could last many
times longer today superconductors need
to be below minus 100 degrees Celsius to
work crucially the Korean team claims
their lead-based material works at room
temperature and above plus 100 their
non-peer-reviewed papers included
details of the molecular structure and a
relatively easy recipe guide for how to
make the material step by step
q a worldwide Rush among scientists to
cook up batches of LK 99 to see if they
would work and so far it hasn't met that
Mark
um it doesn't mean that it's the end of
the story just yet the consensus in
recent days is that LK 99 was a false
dome but one of the paper's authors told
a Korean newspaper that a follow-up
study will give better instructions a
month from now there's nothing that
tells us it's not possible so there's no
Theory or principle that tells us that
there's any limit to the temperature at
which superconductivity can exist after
the hype there is still hope Unlike
superconductors scientific discovery
never comes without resistance Redmond
Shannon Global News London and that's
global national for this Tuesday night
I'm Farah Nasser tonight's your Canada
is Morning Star Mill in St Catharines
Ontario until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]
ha
thank you